que les jackson lakers
mais je me repose
la planète
j'avais écrit préféré
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
intello
vue
toute ta vérité
la vie
s
saberla m'a passé lancier de solidité
tous mes amis m'échapperont des jours
sonne vraiment bien
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Salut
l'été
la plante et les samares
Oh
ré
vraiment
ce sont des problèmes qui sont à la fois
avant tout
[Musique]
Voilà
Voyons voir
[Applaudissements]
mais mon visage
ça c'est bien
et l'hebdomadaire
Oh
que se passait
plus
Oh
j
alors débarrassez-vous de vos marchandises
de cette taille si fait
la fête est 1er
et le soleil
[Musique]
ef
la base s'appelle la peau
[Musique]
une chèvre
en passant
Hélène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
[Musique]
cette habitude
si je mets l'imbrication et 2012
m'a fait faire des tournées sur les pistes
à propos de quand il prévaut toujours
à présent
je
[Musique]
plus maintenant
bien
c'est tout
pourquoi
[Musique]
ton
mais
[Musique]
de l'autre côté
pour l'esprit
Il ne m'a pas toujours semblé qu'un nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Salut
Tu verras
qu'en penses-tu
de telle manière
[Applaudissements]
c'est avec samedi
[Musique]
ça n'a jamais été un peu
Ceci n'est pas de l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en manière d'être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la comtesse
Heures
la vérité est qu'il en est ainsi
Pas de contenu
a savoir
la tragédie
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
st.moritz ici ce sera décidé alors
quand tu me donnes ça sait que ce n'est pas mal
de supposer que cette maison
heureux de me faire
votre base de déchirure non voisine n'est pas non plus
juste pour tuer aux confins siderar
nous étions l'accord intact à la fin peut-être
et un intérêt cristallin et rien
c'est bien ce sera qu'il est destiné alors
quand tu me donnes peu d'avasa
Je voulais une maison qui tue ta vie et pas
manger ne nous illumine ni ton soin du visage
déchirer pas dire juste la question de la
cuisine on veut juste un taquito de china
bien
moi non
[Musique]
si heureux
je
situation intérieure de la nation
population de la nation à laquelle je
Je vais militantisme à mon impression gauche
mettre fin à des voyages en ligne
ça peut être quotidien ils ont dit pour la réalité
m
[Musique]
ma vie
non
commencer la citation en étant un peu plus en arrière
tovar l'a poursuivi ce qui
ou non
ré
[Musique]
qui se bat
Oui je l'ai fait
à moi
[Musique]
porte sur lui cela avec louanges et
chasse
dans mon lit existe
à ton amour
En retour
[Musique]
un mois
l'équipe est plus belle marseille et gaza
c'était ma copine quimey qui paye des noeuds
bullet je suis de la viande animale
pleurer 28 ipanema
c'est la plus belle chose qui me soit arrivée
parce que c'est tout
il m'a dit
bien que tout
bien aujourd'hui
il
et ce n'est pas que la mienne
Oui
et quand ça arrive avec un ciel s'ils existent
fermes typiques pour l'invoquer ton amour
l'amour
[Musique]